pop
[Musique]
qui va m'arriver
bonjour
kate faubel moyenne non j'ai pas envie
de rire quitté ma robe de chambre a
expliqué moi ce que vous faites chez moi
à un possible des sushis j'étais prise
par l'averse
alors j'ai retiré mon tailleur pour
faire sécher montagne parce que vous ne
voulez pas sortir de chez moi je veux
trop plein gré c'est très sain alors le
commissariat des bons enfants et comme
un mois connaissez pas attendu que
françoise leclerc
la fille de la cousine de votre oncle à
t'aimer petite simone tante gertrude et
non de l'ordre et donc je rendrai les
morts comment il est mort mais là c'est
là que vous êtes la petite françois j'ai
grandi non monsieur le commissaire ne
sais pas danser les tenez c'est pas une
erreur c'est une petite cousine
salade et une boîte de cassoulet savoir
moi qui régale
il a fait cas les ans la star
attendez quand il s'appelle le début
très bien mais tour d'argent c'est pas
bien assis dessus et qu'est ce que vous
faites en cas de choc
oui
une cathédrale
m'appelait tante henriette n'est pas un
petit peu de monnaie rob simmons est
monté
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas laisser au vestiaire
c'est très important je cache mon linge
ou là dedans alors que je pensais sygic
l'attention
et
comptez partir aux etats-unis avec sa
wii on avions décollent pas fait mentir
[Musique]
enfin vous savez ce que ça représente sa
à new york une chambre d'hôtel et de
saucisses a besoin d'être consciente
toujours j'étais comme débrouiller pour
les jours après après je verrai les amis
ne va pas encore non babou ne manque pas
d'un certain toupet
[Musique]
j'en ai dans le train c'est super cheap
mais attendez je vais vous emmener j'ai
un ami qui a notament derrière notre
dame est non non j'ai pas du tout envie
d'aller me coucher quand on est 48
heures à paris une autre chose à faire
qu'à dormir et qua non à ribagnac vous
allez tous vous faire visiter
[Musique]
je trouve ça fort
métro vers 6 heures
c'est vrai c'est beaucoup moins chaude
aucune
le projet
vous connaissez l'image
oui
là bas les gens travaillent mangent le
coche face à toute leur vie
par thomas yeux
oui mais là bas rien d'autre
c'est pour saluer ses jurés d'une vive
que dans une chrono
je finis par te passe
la catéchèse
un bouclier
c'est pas gérer leur avance au pas de
charge plusieurs ont pris
sagem à des prêts
champs elysées
enfin à vous avez tout dit chic alors
qu'il ya une oeuvre
et pour ne rien vous cacher je sors de
trois semaines de cliniques alors je
suis un peu
un accident du travail et puis demain
matin moi je vais au bio
comme à limoges
macgé
marchand ça ira mieux
et bien de prendre un peu l'air
l'apport à parisien vous tenez plutôt
mal le coup l'équipement dre de l'evian
depuis trois semaines alors là vous
faites comme moi au bas des jus de
fruits rudy mois et des mouches
il va me tuer et je jure qu'il va vous
tous les hits i
[Musique]
oui je le suis
s'ils m'avaient fois les eaux se sauver
que je pourrais écrire
oui
bush
allez bien
on a perdu assez de temps allait bien
écoutez j'ai pas l'habitude de mai les
scènes de ménage mais malleray
[Musique]
on crée avc
il a passé une bonne nuit excellent
sinon le patron a demandé ce matin
oui aucun sujet baïla une affaire
délicate confié naturellement en
contient des fermières d'avancé que j'en
prends moi l'inquiète pas c'est arrangé
commence à ranger comme n'était pas
arrivé ce matin à 11 heures le patron un
truc était fatigué non il a confié la
férarock renard au petit chrono il est
en progrès ils montent à oui ça tombe
très bien parce que justement ce matin
j'ai pas envie de travailler tous
et comme cette palette on capte de
points ici
oui une demoiselle françoise leclerc et
bien regarder si la clé est au tableau
bon je rappellerai savait pas qu'il
avait une serre non c'est une drag queen
ou une longe tempête eut vous empêche de
réfléchir
qu'est ce que tu fabriques du cherche
l'inspiration tu écris des verts voyez
c'est un peu ça peut t'aider je
cherchais un non moins trois syllabes
qui publie par ski
[Musique]
le bruit cinq mois 3 c'est possible de
parler trouver tu parles d'un boulot un
classement qui commence par l'intérieur
s'il opte ça n'existe pas c'est vraiment
important
non à en soi j'essaie de vous avoir
depuis ce matin maintenant c'est tout à
faire oui enfin ça pourrait aller mieux
une seule question est ce que vous vous
souvenez du nom du gars d'hier soir non
enfin écoutez je suis parfois vous
l'avez noté sur un morceau de papier non
oui oui oui bien sûr je vais les voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors oui non mariage
du courage le bois
non
écoutez je supplie essayez de vous
souvenir sa série dans ce qui n'en
commet pour dîner oui d'accord je veux
bien entendu à leur écoute et dormez un
peu et je passe vaut prendre l'air 9
heures bien comment vous êtes folle
c'est moi qui vous invite alors à l'eau
françois moal est aux petites cousines
elle est complètement cliquer elle a pas
cent balles en poche album invité chez
maxim françoise lensoise en soi
[Musique]
où
résumons-nous vous êtes cousin votre
cousine à rivière à paris et se rend
directement chez vous elle passe la
soirée et une partie de la nuit avec
vous oui elle descend dans un hôtel
indiqué par vous oui et à paris elle ne
connaissait que vous oui c'est en béton
honorin voulais pas me faire le numéro à
moi mais mon cher comme écouter renard
c'est pas le moment de nous casser les
pieds
si quelqu'un doit résoudre cette
histoire c'est moi je suis navré leclerc
mais c'est moi quand la charge de
l'enquêté alors nettement seul témoin
faux dieu je vous interromps jeu à vous
le prenez comme ça c'est très bien
j'apprendrai à toutes vos questions
mais seulement en présence de mon avocat
ou les
bonjour l'uci
comment mettre en sommeil mal est encore
dans le coma il n'y a pas fait parler
heureusement pour nous que le juge veut
connaît pourquoi je lui dans le dossier
les conclusions déposées par renard si
j'étais juge et non votre à droite car
je vous inquiète pas cap sur l'autre à
fribourg on va le juger en art ne
connaissent pas la moitié des éléments
qu'il faut connaître dans cette histoire
voyons le quai des martyrs
non c'est un passé que ça ferait jouer
alors moi dans ces conditions comment je
peux continuer à vous défendre enfin le
suspense est tout de même pas que je
suis coupable pour moi votre cousine a
été victime de rab l'hôtel confirmée par
les faits on a retrouvé dans cette
affaire ni papiers ni argent pris
naturellement le passe-temps est orangée
d'ensemble
[Musique]
oui
mais si vous êtes en amour faites-vous
très belle dimanche vous emmène à la
campagne à faire le clair il a combien
d'adjoint l'inspecteur ton sort
plusieurs seul free agent connaît déjà
tous avec vous ça fait 3 lewis et ça ça
fait beaucoup
robin faut ce qu'il faut merci l'état
attendez attendez votre nous on sait
comment compter sur moi je sais il veut
dire à quoi si renard apprend ça c'est
un coin permettre à pied mais t'inquiète
dont le vieux est myope comme une taupe
et a certainement pas reconnu la ville
dollars tu vois qu'il trouve est invité
chez maxime c'est loria tout dans ce cas
j'ai même trouvé la reine que tu
cherchais love qui a besoin d'argent et
elle a fait chanter ce biais l'hostis tu
te rends compte du culot de cette gamine
malheureusement le jeu est d'être dans
un jeu et s'y est brûlé
adieu les états unis bon alors écoute
relève mois tous les biens lorsqu'il
part il faut pas y avoir tellement je
suis bien lorsque mes deux morts quand
ça vers 10 927 28 je n'ai jamais connu
[Musique]
j'avais d'afrique au football c'est pour
la vie je verrai bien le ski c'est une
erreur
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est une
erreur c'est la deuxième fois comme des
offres oriane deuxième fois hier c'est
une jeune fille tu venu a demandé plan
mans avec un bain et dames j'adore ses
liens avec quinze airbus a marqué
messieurs billups qui s'il vous plaît
c'est pour accoster main le costume de
deuil
je prends de vomir
vos fournisseurs qui m'a donné votre
adresse sur trois y est restée
c'est pour un métier non mais ça
rapporte
[Musique]
de toute façon ce que pour l'acheteur
alors déjà ce qu'ils ne paieront pas
passer 20 millions vous êtes un naïf je
vous ai tendu un piège vous êtes tombé
dedans les yeux fermés comment mort
avant-hier rue fontaine ça vous dit rien
et hier mais pas reçu la visite d'une
petite blonde avec un béret d'un c'est
moi qui voulais envoyer et vous avez
fait exactement ce que j'attendais d'eux
c'est de dire une bêtise contre notre
silence lui avait remis ça et vous lui
avez promis le reste pour le soir venu
parole vous êtes venus et avec un
couteau
ce faux milowski alors j'étais là avec
un appareil et jai des photos
c'est pour ça que c'est 20 milliards
bah oui des fois on va te faire du mal
merci et un cru et on doit faire ce soir
l'échangeur je change de foot il a
jamais prises contre une somme d'argent
que biais d'autres qui ne possèdent
probablement encore exactement ça la
foire et non ça ne va pas foiré si je
vais demander une petite somme d'argent
il aurait probablement marché pour payer
et après cet aperçu que c'était du bluff
c'est raté en déclin mais moi je porte
ça me paraît logique il doit te
descendre voilà un mois que tu
choisisses de s'enfuir au bout du monde
non il restreint parce que sa boutique
doit servir de couverture à une salle
combine quelconque ya beaucoup trop de
jolies filles là dedans tu vois ce que
je veux dire
et c'est pour ça qu'il a tué la blonde
parce qu'elle en savait trop il y en a
pas pu garder sa langue
alors entre faire sa valise et à
préparer mon cercueil il n'hésitera pas
tu disais froidement tour on vote curie
tubes du temps se fige
mais mon jeu j'ai vu le chirurgien
françoise vient de sortir du coma mais
alors là encore pour trois quatre jours
ce qui fait qu'actuellement on ne peut
absolument pas compter sur son
témoignage il goûte avant de s'offrir
comme cible à bielawski réfléchi de
quand même avoir une autre solution
je bien fait le coeur du problème c'est
la seule façon de le coincer chaîne
oui
oh
mais qui
oui
et elle tombe en table s'il donnait tout
vert râpé membres du boys band où aller
[Musique]
oui
et
qui
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa mort il
chaud
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez des photos
oui
containers l'argent d'abord c'est juste
il
et
[Musique]
oui
bah t'as de la veine une bosse
costil sort de celle qu'un turing
je ne peux me
non rien de grave
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
non
the kills en voiture
hier
je croyais sexe à miami beach cher
cousin ma cicatrice ne m'empêche pas de
me mettre en maillot
on peut pas rentrer d'une pièce j'ai
trouvé un mari sur mesure il est
ailleurs
merci pour tout un toujours ps martone
moite embrassant sa petite françoise
leclerc w qui h hnr junior
oui
[Musique]
ok ce qui peut l'être
et qu'est-ce qui peut pas être toujours
pareil c'est quand on a besoin de lui
qu'il est un ennemi des sur hbo bon
anniversaire nos voeux les plus sincères
et que leur fils et mes enfants je vous
emmène déjeuner dans un petit restaurant
vous m'en direz des nouvelles
où ça du côté du palais bourbon une
cuisine sensationnel les députés en
mangeant c'est malin alors moi qui ai
mal au foie alors au bas tu pourras
toujours te taper des carottes vichy
ah oui ils les font très bien toi si tu
veux que je descends
mais moi ça fait parler mais c'est très
sympathique patron qui a de la gueule
des clients qui arrivent à l'heure
[Musique]
l'ambiance est chaude on ovi store de
l'économie c'est véronique qui lit pas
les journaux de mode ou tout bon ma
femme et moi j'ai eu à sa photo par un
modérateur trois fois par an kwh est
inconnue jérôme si le petit poucet enfin
bon à mes enfants c'est ma tournée
qu'est ce que je vous offre
moi j'suis autre coach tu es tu là c'est
du bon je vous le recommande chamouton
barça mais jamais défendu leur voix soit
d'accord et il faut que je suis dans la
course pour la vie 3
alors qu'est ce que je vous donne
comment vous avez entre 18 à huy dans
cette saison chez les pros mais je
garantis la phrygie garantit la
fraîcheur bombe à 18 ans mais ça se
refuse à moi je prends ça il vaut peine
tu me feras mourir d'une prise de poids
du jambon devrait pas en prendre enfin
tu es moi j'aime pas ça alors patron
vous allez me donner une galantine d'un
bon alors je dis une garantie et 2011 ou
pour 12 et dans des préjugés ne savons
si je meurs tu me battre
voilà c'est trop et enfin stephen jones
et pas cher je ne pensais pas les
ricains de toute façon je vous demande
c'est important il a sonné au moins
quatre fois merci à l'est alors
alors quoi vous connaissez
oui c'est véronique marie thérèse
leterrier dit véronique ça j'ai eu des
tas de fouad et adam avait lui demandé
des tas de choses mais pas ses papiers
elle était au restaurant même temps que
moi déjeuner à midi
pourquoi le commissariat central du 8e
vient de téléphoner
marie thérèse leterrier les deux
véronique a été assassiné aux environs
de 14h 15h il ya une heure à l'entrée de
service de la maison de couture le frein
du 14 avenue matignon où elle allait
présenter la collection arrive à lever
risée à bout portant
je pensais que ça vous intéresserait
j'ai eu tort
bon ça va merci
ça sera sa dernière couverture à
spirituel alors races de poules la
hauteur du sein gauche
le coup a dû être tirée à bout portant
et avec un très gros calibres mort
instantanée à témoin pour l'ombre
l'assassin puisse faire la malle comme
il voulait on a trouvé une arme
pas encore on va chercher c'est pas une
petite affaire
ces boîtes là c'est une passade
merveilleuse mais alors derrière
soir de donne
caprice
façon laissez-moi m'étonner du peu
d'émotion qui sont anglo créé ici la
mort de mademoiselle véronique et
particulièrement chez vous n'aimiez pas
beaucoup je n'ai pas à aimer ou ne pas
aimer les mannequins de cette maison un
mannequin est un employé et toute la
presse que les hebdomadaires leur
consacre ne peut pas influencer mon
attitude à leur égard
j'ai passé l'âge de m'intéresser aux
débordements de ces jeunes personnes
d'ailleurs j'aurais trop de travail
monsieur oui mais ses sorties
je n'ai pas vraiment péché ma lame et
une dernière question savez vous si
mademoiselle véronique avec un ami je
trouve c'est masculin bien singulier
avoir la grâce que mais ce monsieur à se
faire remarquer alors dépêchez vous
dépêchez vous plaît je crois qu'il est
utile de vous recommander la discrétion
n'est ce pas je vous laisse avec votre
collaborateur
non parce qu'elle allait bien on doit
pas être tout à fait son genre alors
hélas rien interdiction de parler
pendant la collection
[Musique]
alors restera tester dit oui déjà
c'est jérôme oui c'est l'inspecteur
leclet des dons gérons je voulais vous
demander un renseignement ce monsieur
qui vient avec la grande véronique
l'advenue oui c'est ça et vous avez pas
par hasard laisser un téléphone ou une
adresse
je suis absolument un curieux monsieur
leclerc si jamais j'avais cru vous
l'aimiez j'y tenais bien sûr elle était
ce qu'il était mais je la préférais aux
autres
excusez moi mais vous êtes disputé chez
jérôme oui plus violent jeu contient
difficilement nous trop de sang comme on
dit pourquoi vous ne soupçonnez vous
conviendrait que le faite vous êtes
disputé avec véronique une heure avant
sa mort
c'était une coïncidence fâcheuse oui
c'est vrai et quand l'avez vous quitter
j'ai pour incarner ont peut-être après
la sortie du restaurant
oui le mans continue à disputer dans
l'ouverture elle voit sa bêtise nous
allons partir ce soir
pas chez lui jouera sa propre et
subitement lâché les commandes et à
table je vous de sorte qu est ressorti à
1h30 du restaurant et je sais j'y arrive
et vous avez laissé véronique 13h45 et
où ça à l'étoile c'est elle qui ouvre
effectivement lui restait juste le temps
de s'en rendre avenue matignon à pied à
quelle heure et vous arrivez à votre bio
les deux heures et demie comme ce livre
et qu'est ce que vous avez fait entre
temps a vu rouler en voiture dans le
bois pour me remettre les besoins d
excuser moi je meurent de soif région
vous imprègne
et l'on sait tout ce que vous avez comme
alibi pourquoi un ennui mais parce qu'on
peut très bien imaginer que vous avez
laissé véronique à l'étoile vous êtes
allez vous dissimuler dans l'entrée de
service de la maison de couture et que
vous l'avez tous et j'en oublie
on m'avait dit qu'elle a été tuée à 2h15
oui à ce moment là je prends les deux
laissant sa venue de la reine à boulogne
à vous êtes sûr de la wii le pompiste
écouter les informations à paris inter
il vous connaît
non
je sois soit soit soit 60 de soif
g soit soir
sa rue
bru
anthony boissière
mais de les battre
avant le psg soit revenue espoir merci
monsieur l'advenue vous n'êtes pas
coupable mais on est maire
m
et marie
c'est un mois soit 100 m et vol
on nous a dit si j'ai peur qu'on vous
suive à la limite de la préfecture
allons rester tranquilles mais quelle
heure est il nous dit vous avez écrit
très peur mais si leclerc fait délirer
pendant vingt-quatre 24 heures
j'adhère bois zone et par les huîtres ne
sais pas encore puisque vous êtes
réveillé les supporters ne vous dit pas
sur tout et mon collègue président
américain mais lui il a repris
connaissance depuis ce matin il est dans
la chambre à côté
bon
[Musique]
oui
tenir
[Musique]
holly oh
non
[Musique]
ces mois galtier et tu m'entends khalti
aide et c'est moi que tu me reconnais
pas mais qu'est ce que tu fous là même
chose que toi là une semaine
[Musique]
ce serait pas pour les huit ans parce
que ces données qui a mangé les huîtres
et comment il va donner le rail va bien
de nous voir tout ça il n'a même pas un
bon os x
ça s'est formée à van la parra juste du
tout la même chose ça je sais moi moi
toi ta commande et la gabegie manger
louis abbès oui moi j'ai pris une
blanquette 2 alors j'ai vu du beaujolais
a prévu de crème caramel de plateau de
fromages écoute norick arrête de
réfléchir tu veux un l'année en veine
fixer tout à l'heure ils sont en train
de terminer ce tour et pas me faire le
plaisir d'aller te coucher
[Musique]
alors l enquête données interrogé
l'advenue wade
il a vérifié sur la libye qui tient
[Musique]
je
pourquoi je crois que je pilotais
dollars à brest on rit mais fonctionne
pas je vous ai tiré d'assez déjà bien
beau car il s'agit bien d'une
intoxication alimentaire
c'est le résultat des analyses vous avez
été empoisonnés aux mots-clés stoll de
la mort aura probablement dissous dans
un liquide alcoolisé il ya de fortes
chances qu'on ait voulu vous faire
disparaître mieux voilà le scotch et
altier mois au lab et du scotch au
restaurant
[Musique]
dites-lui encore m6 le clair qu'on est
désolé pour les huits c'est vraiment de
malchance il ya des tas de clients
comment manger cette semaine il aurait
rien arrivé ici je suis tombé sur une
mauvaise et la photo est ce à quoi nous
allons non non non non merci non non il
faut que je rentre dans les courses à
faire à lecce dame a donc on n'a pas de
me demander de raconter un tuyau à gaz
et la casse et le ciel n'est pas un
marchand de couleurs dans quoi un peu
plus bas à droite un certain merci
c'est incroyable incroyable mais tu es
certain tu m'as déjà vu de rapporter des
points seulement à la bombe alors oui
oui la bouteille de scotch a disparu de
sa place oui le père jérôme a l'habitude
d'acheter du mortes et stone saison
d'argent de couleur jaune un des seuls
du quartier il est basque il a du jambon
de bayonne dans sa chambre alors eh bien
alors dans une cave lérins impuni ah oui
mais non non non non non il ne dit pas
que le monde est stone est arrivé par
hasard dans la bouteille de whisky toi
mais tu n'y crois pas ce qui voudrait
dire qu'il ya un assassin chaise a pesté
dit non j'y crois pas
enfin pourquoi moi et pourquoi moi je
les connais encore moins que toi et
pourquoi pas quelqu'un d'autre le
bouillon dont eur il nous était
peut-être pas destiné à nous mais alors
à qui met ses principales n'ont
maintenant je le souhaite jean tu sais
pas l'air de faire dodo
non je vous en prie à retenez vous savez
ce que vous feriez si vous étiez gentil
mais c'est aussi par mademoiselle ce que
je voulais vous dire ce n'est pas
d'aller dormir mais depuis deux jours
que j'entends parler qui est une chose
que j'ai remarqué aussi principal swiss
qui personne ne vous la service j'ai
bien compris vous vous êtes servi tout
seul mais la raison elle a parfaitement
raison à l'oisel jeanne massa déjà
j'avais quelque chose de très important
à vous dire voilà vous êtes très jolie
vous avez des yeux d'un bleu délicieux
et j'ai été un imbécile de pam ont
attrapé reçus par pierre ginabat pierre
je devrais faire comme sa poche la
dispense de la réflexion bon alors
revenons à nos moutons réitère ma
question si on n'a pas voulu nous
empoisonner nous qui est temps voulu
empoisonner a fire par écoute ça marie
thérèse leterrier dit véronique les lots
6 octobre 1936 arrighi basses pyrénées
fil de l'eau derrière mon mécanicien et
deux à pester gi jane après c'est
exigeant mais elles étaient cousines
issu de germain jérôme bon et alors en
arrivant à paris
véronique a vécu deux ans chez ses
cousins quoi avait de quoi être intime
non mais tu veux dire que oui mais alors
si on a empoisonné pourquoi la descendre
après qu'est ce qu'on risque vérifier un
rien vérifions à l'eau le standard
voulez vous me passez l'institut médico
légal s'il vous plaît bonjour jeunes
c'est assez pour ça c'est pour une
autopsie
non non on doit cette petite le poison
que c'est le bon vieux attendant vous
êtes des drôles de policiers vous n'êtes
même pas foutu de vos souvenirs si c'est
jérôme rothen qui nous a servi sur la
fin pour rendre compte de l'importance
du témoignage l'avenue matignon c'est
tout près rien de plus facile que de
sortir des sens de la petite et revenir
elle tourne une page ne soit pas nous
faire de sol bon alors mais alors on est
partis moi mon vieux en échec la peine
de vous offrir un déjeuner pour vous
rafraîchir la mémoire et véronique elle
a pris un double scotch c'est oui comme
d'habitude d'ailleurs il ya qu'elle est
monsieur leclerc qui en prennent si
antoine qui les a servis
dieu sur bien sûr je l' ai vu partir
antoine par la cour à 1h45 avec une
boîte à chaussures sous le bras je
revenais des waters
même que ça m'a étonné par ce qu'il
avait dit avant qu'il allait tirer du
vin à la cab voyage ont caché son jeu
moi je sais quand on est plongeur dans
un restaurant
on voit beaucoup de choses c'est pas moi
je n'ai pas tué bon sang vous a vu vous
dissimulez larmes dans une boîte à
chaussures
et oui un gros calibre à ce camouflet
pas comme ça c'est pas vrai alors on
continue à prétendre que vous avez été
chercher du vin à la cave pendant une
heure c'est ridicule ça ne tient pas
debout
mais quand je pense que c'est pour une
garce pareil je veux bien toléré parce
que je vous connais mais vous dépasser
les limites
jérôme ne compliquez pas la vie hein
c'est déjà assez difficile d'admettre
que les gens pour qui on avait une
certaine estime sont des assassins vous
allez sortir
bon vous le prenez comme ça alors ça
change tout monsieur apesteguy le et
bien à revolver dans votre tiroir caisse
non monsieur apesteguy je suis un vieux
clients ce revolver que vous avez piqué
en 1918 et qui dort dans votre tiroir
caisse depuis tout ce temps là un moser
calibre 11 exactement le même que celui
qui a tué mademoiselle maïté leterrier
dit véronique utile je les ai perdus où
ça dans la seine répondez répondait
jérôme vous savez que ça va chercher
loin de complicité d'assassinât et c'est
le temps qu'ils se moquent ils étaient
honneur voilà qui est plus raisonnable
par jalousie
je voulais pas qu'elle parte qu'il est
devenu mais me jour l'aurait tué c'est
ce que vous avez fait il paraît
et pourtant elle avait refusé de partir
puisque la devenue la gifler vue dixon
partait pas avec le dos nu qu'elle
partirait avec une autre nom venu ici
pour me montre des hommes avec qui elle
était moi j'étais obligé de les servir
j'ai envie de me tuer après c'est elle
qui venait me chercher
ça doit lui faire plaisir et vous avez
pris un vol vers dans le tiroir caisse
et vous êtes allés l'attendre avenue
matignon et vous l'avez tué quel dommage
que je ne vois pas quoi vous mentez ou
et jouit par omission vous oubliez de
dire que la personne que vous avez
descendu avenue matignon était déjà
presque morte empoisonnée
oui et il l'a tuée que pour que la
police ne puisse pas constaté
l'empoisonnement mort foudroyante par
balles de moser pas d'autopsié
donc pas de poison taille compris n'ont
pas tout à fait alors je vais vous
expliquer
antoine ne savais pas que le whisky
était en bois zone et c'est pas lui qui
a versé le poison la personne qui l'a
fait c'est elle par jalousie elle était
jalouse depuis huit ans depuis le jour
où véronique était arrivé ici et elle
l'a tuée parce qu'elle voyait son
antoine se détruire petit à petit devant
ses yeux
vous voulez que je vous explique comment
ça s'est réellement passé
alors revenons au moment où nous sommes
entrés tous les trois dans le bistrot et
la gifle
véronique est sorti avec la devenu pub
long des roses et jaunes tonton bistrot
du les bonnets et oui c'est véronique tu
lis pas les journaux de mode joue
beaucoup ma femme et achète à sa photo
paraîtront à 20 par an en couverture un
d'être inconnu ça donne ça fait
aujourd'hui alors que jérôme hélas oui
j'ai eu des centres jones est ce que tu
peux rien finit elle est sifflée twh
nets et toi t'as même pas que lui auriez
tord dans la figuration type pourquoi
pas avec toi tu t'en vas une fois pour
toutes non je ramenais quelqu'un d'autre
et il va continuer à laisser marcher
dessus comme une paillasse ou non mais
elle te mange un plus jeune et si tu en
verras plus qu'est-ce que tu suis pris
de la mort-aux-rats j'aimais dans un
apéritif c'est toi qui lui avait été
tout à l'heure tu es folle secours est
un professeur
et alors c'est la saveur tout de suite
antoine va chercher ma mère dans la
caisse et puis tireur tu sais où elle et
sa famille dit mme a été oui tu la tuera
tous le chargeur on saura jamais qui
laisse à désirer et souris tu retournes
s'ouvrit leclerc qui l'appelaient
bouteille de whisky y en a vus tuer le
revolver reste à l'achat
et vous nous avez servi à déjeuner en
vous demandant à chaque instant si on
n'allait pas craquer sous vos yeux
ça m'a heureusement nous nous ne vivrons
pas double scotch mais un peu de whisky
dans beaucoup d'eau et vous avez dû
passer un fichu quart d'heure en vous
demandant si la barre antoine elle est
arrivée à rejoindre à temps véronique je
me trompe
oui
et voilà quelle heure est il
8 heures l'heure du dîner il va falloir
trouver un autre restaurant excusez moi
j'ai pas très fin
[Musique]
oui
ne pas piquer
orange toi
inspectant les faire c'est comme un
cancer mais monsieur et si tu crois
vraiment qu'il y ait autre chose
alors c'est moi qui ai entendu tous les
rêveurs que tu le prétend le palier le
monsieur martin du colonel oui alors
circulé tout le monde donnait n'empêche
que c'est moi qui téléphonique
évidemment je ne vais pas courir les
rues en pyjama
quel étage ou 3e à droite qu'à gauche
oui c'est vous et avec vous et moi j'ai
pas nommé les allées charge maximum
trois personnes
j'ai touché à rien vous pensez eh bien
vous avez très bien fait pour monsieur
ses yeux pour voir et valverde
ordonnance 7,65 c'est bien ça je l'avais
reconnu innocent parce que martel a dû
être officier s'est passé à quelle heure
les coups de feu vers 9h30
9h23 très exactement je me rasais marié
ou bien sûr j'ai même un fils qui n'ont
pas vous lui lui nous passâmes pas de
femmes donc pas d'ennuis vous êtes priés
d'assister le priés d'assister au convoi
funèbre de monsieur robert l'inr décédé
dans sa 60e année une mairie de sa nièce
le choeur est ce qu'on m'a dit marie de
sa nièce de la part de madame jacqueline
in her son épouse de monsieur même pour
l'ong madame van julian de monsieur
martel et ultime ses parents et amis le
service religieux sera célébré mardi 14
à 9 heures en l'église saint-pierre et
demain sur par un lieu où chine tient
deux sèvres
j'étais en ce moment oui
curieuse chalon et bien non c'était
brouillard à prendre nous semble un poil
ou au cimetière
d'autres sont partis les premiers
d'autres suivront mais toujours une âme
d'élite hier à prendre la relève
marie leblanc vous étiez une véritable
artiste
j'avais personne n'oubliera votre
magistrale interprétation de la brève au
théâtre de la madeleine en 1912
coloratoure sublime
et
c'est la veuve voilà binaire
après quand je lui ai serré la main de
combler comme une feuille c'est pas le
moment de l'annoncer l'amendement -
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là-bas et c'est de
savoir le nom de tous les gens qui sont
ici on le fait parce que je suis sentie
si il pouvait pas être chez martell à la
vie
et puis ça déblatère tu crois toujours
que martel a été tué devant sa famille à
bien
un spectacle pour les judiciaire entrée
quel est l'objet de votre visite
voilà le sort semble s'acharner sur vous
j'ai une autre mauvaise nouvelle à vous
apprendre quoi qu'y at il votre oncle
monsieur marcel et il sait pourquoi
n'est-il pas à l'enterrement
il est mort oui une balle dans la tête
ce qui est arrivé ce que voulait dire
je ce sont là les secrets de famille
adam il ya mort d'homme et je dois
savoir toute la vérité n'est pas belle
dans mon métier j'ai l'habitude au non
plus mon mari était associé tu m'avais
associés l'un deux volets l'autre lequel
mon oncle
il avait comme et récemment des
indélicatesses qui avait ni mon mari au
bord de la faillite de votre mari
n'avait pas porté plainte
non tout parent garde pour moi et
scandaient leurs et éclaboussé toute la
famille gide faire il a obligé mon oncle
se reconnaître coupable dans une
profession etc
l'anc et d'attention
celle de préserver ses intérêts sa
réputation comme l'a fait dit aurait été
déclarée comprend
j'imagine l'intérieur de martel en
recevant le faire-part donc la préférez
le suicide au scandale c'était bien à
100 caractères
bienvenue une dernière question madame
savez vous où se trouve cette lettre je
pense que mon mari qui l'a déposé dans
son coffre un maquilleur misa sans
l'avouer je sais pas je ne sais pas
aucune importance je trouverais
excusez moi encore là alors mais non je
regrette monsieur l'inspecteur mais
monsieur l'inr ne m'a jamais confié un
document de ce genre enfin écoutez c'est
insensé qu'on n'arrive pas avec la main
sur cette lettre tue pas étonné comment
ça oui monsieur linéaire était un homme
très bon je les imagine fort bien
exigeant de son associé une lettre pour
lui faire peur et d'un déchirant
quelques heures plus tard la nature est
monsieur linéarité cardiaque
depuis plusieurs années il était
condamné par les médecins or en cas de
mort brutale
ce qui hélas est advenu cette lettre est
automatiquement mis monsieur martel sont
l'oncle dans une fâcheuse position
monsieur linéaire ne l'aurait pas voulu
alors si on admet que je suis c'est de
maarten c'est fait pour rien c'est que
s'est posée manqué c'est loin d'être
inutile mais pour que ont manqué c'est
nettement insuffisant qui vous manque
une certitude
le che martel on le voyait pratiquement
jamais il avait décapité dans la sphère
il se doutait un peu d'huile commercial
en dilettante mais l'âme de la faire
c'était monsieur linéaire la sphère du
match est plutôt mal
vous savez monsieur linéaire il était
comme tous les papes ont créé hier entre
les gorges
il est certain que depuis son mariage à
présent dans la maison n'est plus la
même
j'ai eu quelques échéances difficiles ça
coûte cher une jolie pub
oulala qui le dépôt dont colonel vous
êtes mon principal témoin je pense que
je peux me fier à votre oreille puisque
vous reconnaissez un revolver en hausse
entre sa détonation
donc ce matin là il n'y avait personne
d'autre ici que marten personne je n'ai
rien entendu
alors il se serait suicidé
le formel par le moindre qu'un doigt
je suis sourd mois mais si j'étais
toujours madame je leur ai pas entendu
ou cool revolver et je ne me serais
partant au gérant du charivari que vous
faites en sortant les poubelles mais
sans être sous on peut tout de même être
insensible à certains songent entend
parfaitement c'est parfait mon colonel
je ne mettrai pas votre parole en doute
avez vous quelques détails
supplémentaires à me donner
monsieur l'inspecteur je vis seule je
fais mon bar chez moi même si je ne pars
pas maintenant tous les commerçants
seront fermés oui je dispose et je vous
en prie merci et bon appétit et moi nous
restait une seconde parce que j'ai
l'impression que j'avais pouvoir compter
que sur votre propre témoignage mais
c'est pas pour dire mais le colonel avez
raison je devais trouver teinte dans
l'âme
quel genre de gens seraient monsieur
martel ou s'ils recevaient pour ainsi
dire jamais personne ne veut y soigner
quelques fautes mais c'est tout quand
les gens montent on sait pas toujours où
vivent 1 je vois monsieur martel ce que
paie d'une association sportive
ah oui il était président j'avais vu ça
dans son courrier moi ça dans son
courrier sur l'angle après bien sûr il
disait même que c'est grâce à lui si sa
nièce avait été une championne
pourquoi parce que madame inea a été
championne de natation
oui j'ai vu une photo d'elle un jour
dans un journal fait pas tomber si bien
fait que ça avait le maillot de bain
c'est très difficile à porter tiens
curieux et dont il était plutôt pauvre
monsieur martel et avait raison oui
évidemment
et martel a martelé bien que oui
non ici la rubrique sportive martel lui
ce qu'il est mais surtout dans la
natation c'était les nageuses mais je
crois qu'il s'est jamais mis la loue et
sa nièce à sa nièce était différent une
vraie sportive mais la voilà à melbourne
elle y était allée avec l'équipe du
relais 4 x 100 il avait la grande classe
personne n'a compris ton pc marié
surtout avec un homme de l'âge de
l'hiver n'a cru un coup de tête
et cette petite la pièce phare ça c'est
à dire aux ailes et jacqueline était
inséparable on les voyait toujours
ensemble en voyage au spectacle ont
compétitionné les monter un numéro de
plongeon faisait le double saut berrios
tenant par la main pu le faire on les
appelait les sisters et c'est à dire à
ce que c'est réglé
elle a continué est à paris mais non non
non en ce moment il ya les championnats
35-12 attendait mais finale sont
dimanche alors ça a commencé il ya deux
jours c'est toujours ça non plus ça ne
colle pas et pourquoi tu veux pas mettre
que mattel se soit suicidé une idée
comme ça
ah oui mais diminuent qui repose sur
rien ça alors là ni mobile ni suspense
mon hypothèse reviendrait à succès
martel alors la clean air sa nièce il
risque de tout c'est bien me fatigue pas
ils étaient ruinés
ah oui un immeuble à neuilly 2000 royal
dutch et 20 millions en banque au titre
avec seulement dans le moyen de voler
son associé mes enfants mais ta vie tu
sais madame li na qui a inversé les
roule et son mari qui était ruinée c'est
lui qui a cherché à ruiner martel ayant
pour ça qu'on n'a pas retrouvé la même
heure et quand une jeune femme épouse un
vieux mari ce qui l attend des
compensations la manque de chance y
meurt elle se retrouve veuve et pour et
tout à coup je dis conte de fées l'oncle
meurt à son tour pour tout arranger
et ben non c'est trop beau tu veux dire
que la tête sous l'eau bon alors mal
mais ça colle pour contrer les bons
coins mais non mais ça connaît pas elle
n'a pas pu tuer son nom puisqu'elle
était à long terme en a
à moins qu'un petit ami soit chargé du
travail mais alors qui est à partager en
frais ou en soeur pour vous narguer
cette façon la bonne place aux mafias
jamais bien compris
les dents jambes personne dans la
famille
pascal heroes et l'a10 d'abord menacé
un bon plan
au ballon
très en forme
sous la nef specter leclerc de la pj ah
oui en réponse à tout
pas de vacances pour les poulets
la clim les maires ont envoyé deux jours
non
depuis qu'elle est mariée complètement
perdus de vue voici les deux systèmes
et la vie
en arrive à l'effigié plus une histoire
je suis venu exprès de paris pour vous
raconter une histoire de moyens
si cette confusion ou m'arrêter
sinon c'est moi qui vous arrive
vous écoute
voilà
pendant que votre amie jacqueline
intérêt son mari
vous lui réserve une surprise
laquelle une bonne surprise avec un
héritage au boucher son angle m'appelle
on avait de bonnes la vidéo
pas plus
j'ai appris par les journaux peu marre
qu'elle avait vécu à 9 heures du matin
9h23 exactement à cette heure-là
moi j'étais dans le train celui de tous
le ca carvin
la voilà
on n'a pas demandé mon billet
quelle chance exceptionnelle
contrôler
ainsi mademoiselle durance
l'imagination d'une fois
c'est gentil de me préparer ma note tout
partait déjà oui hélas les dents à
quelle heure et le train pour paris ve
12h15 rien avant non mais si vous êtes
pressés vous pouvez le temps dans
l'avion
évidemment on peut prendre l'avion
l'avion mais oui l'avion je n'avais pas
pensé à l'avion merci
et pas mal à manier rosella non elle a
dû abandonner pour quelle raison je ne
sais pas un malade
et oui il y à un quart environ
là
arrivé en bas je prends pas envoyé elle
a pris l'avion à orly à 11 heures elle
est arrivée à 12h30 à toulouse comme si
elle avait pris trop à quoi et à 9h30
elle était chez martell c'est elle qui a
fait le coup son ensemble se trouve est
elle trop de contraintes dans le biais
d'une habitude dans tu sais pas que des
compressions de bio on en fait pas joli
bond à leur écoute ton amoureux on
surveillait frontières dont jacques
liminaire il faut qu'elle se cramponnant
shenzhen jusqu'à mon retour un tu
commences par et de son téléphone en
dérangement s'est plaint de son courrier
d'accord et produits elle était de
recevoir des mauvaises graines pour
enfants et puis un talent une planque
devant chez eux avant que jamais
je
allô allô allô allô
[Musique]
et là vous inquiétez pas c'est
l'inspecteur leclerc
je vous ai appelé au téléphone pour vous
prévenir de ma visite seulement pas
pareil est en dérangement
en effet faisant bêtement d'avoir un
appareil en dérangement quelqu'un a un
peu cherché à vous appeler
impossible de répondre au sol mais
suppose que vous n'est pas venu ici pour
me vanter les avantages du téléphone non
je suis venu vous chercher pour une
corde et vous partiez en vacances c'est
embêtant parce qu'alors là ça va vous ça
va vous retardez pourquoi s'il vous
plaît c'est une simple formalité alors
qu'il sera très vite fait on a besoin de
vous pour reconnaître le corps de votre
mari pourquoi et bien la faire de votre
mari va être mise en liquidation alors
le juge d'instruction a demandé
l'exhumation pour éviter toute
contestation des créanciers c'est une
formalité le comprenez très mal
venez je vous accompagner jusqu'à
l'institut médico légal
ce sera très vite fait
et moi est ce que vous comptez reprendre
la compétition un jeu
peut-être qui sait
je suis bien sûr que vous recommencerez
le succès c'est grisant
non
d'être encore très jeune
esch
bien mais l'amateurisme le plus pur
nous verrons les sisters en finale dans
suis certain
family nerfs madame s'il vous plaît
c'est à nous
reconnaissez vous monsieur linéaire
madame ce n'est pas lui c'est pas mon
mari par madame c'est bien ce corps que
nous avons mis en bière devant vous
juste avant la cérémonie
vous étiez bien là madame mais n'ont
qu'à pas être partout à l'enterrement et
chez son oncle vous fatiguez pas on a
arrêté un héros dans la frontière là
tout avoué et dont elle était dévoué
votre petit camarade
vous remplacez à l'enterrement sous les
voiles de deuil pendant vous liquidez
voteront bravo bravo pour la libye s'en
est fallu de peu que ça marche
allez remarquer là
m
non
oui comment as tu compris que c'était
jacqueline qui avait donné son nom
parce qu'un homme qui n'a autant de
verrous à sa forte est un homme qui se
méfie de tout le monde sauf de sa nièce
comme indices sont maigres
oui mais rappelle toi quand nous sommes
allés au cimetière et que j'ai serré la
main de la soi-disant aveugle elle avait
mal au poignet m'a fait ailleurs quand
je suis allé à la piscine et j'ai aidé
and heroes à sortir de l'eau même
réflexe
c'est là que j'ai commencé à comprendre
que j'étais la même personne et que
c'était annie qui avait remplacé
jacqueline à l'enterrement
je suis inspecteur oui monsieur était
contente de la petite mise en scène
oui fabien parfait et alors bravo pour
le cadre d'un remplacement un merci il
n'y a pas deux fois
bonjour à votre charisme
[Musique]